[Music]
in not fair do submitted by fungus spawn
a woman is kicked out of the police
academy after her superiors found
details of her past sucking dick wait
what how does she even get into the
police academy in the first place and
they do the background check [ __ ] it
up hearing the word Police Academy makes
me laugh because of the movie yeah that
movie we do all the sound effects I was
like oh like that here's how the gate uh
so this takes place in Prussia I'm not
sure what their backgrounds if I got
different systems over there
apply do it simultaneously dad is a girl
she's 21 years old her name is Jude Mila
oh I know and Ludmila for real yeah in
our high school Ludmila turned a little
English turn our boy yeah so apparently
she had alcoholic parents I'm not sure
what happened with the dad but it is is
that everybody in Russia is like water
no word for alcoholic everybody just
drink but so I don't know what what's
the deal with her dad but her mom was
arrested like she's in prison over
killing an abusive partner of hers oh
yeah well no that's not the path her DNA
is killer
no so when that whole thing happened
with your parents she was left at a
Russian orphanage and apparently her
parents allowed her to live in a kennel
when she was ya know like a [ __ ] dog
pound yeah like like dogs so she's
trained by corgis okay weird Russian
Shepherds okay
Ludmila adopted mother she's claiming
that the police academy they found out
about her feral pass and so they branded
her as feral and saying surely she's an
animal
yeah and saying that she can never be
become a police officer I love the logic
that's been like her she can't even be a
police dog
because of her feral past I know right
she she could have been a
the k-9 unit yeah that doesn't even
[ __ ] sniff around like the weirdest
things I don't understand how they come
to the conclusion sometimes Russian
logic she's been raised by wolves
surely so that's what they're kind of
claiming right I mean as long as she's
not barking and she can communicate
she's she she knows like she must have
average intelligence for her to at least
get a part of the become a part of the
police academy at least to fill out the
application she did that correct right
so it's not like she was raised by dogs
and then she's barking and she thinks
like she's a dog because I seen that
[ __ ] there's a girl there's this little
girl that like barks and she thinks
she's a dog cuz she was raised by
doggies same [ __ ] alcoholic parents they
left her outside in the backyard and
forgot about her maybe during the
Academy like she was peeing on trees and
[ __ ] no no no wait what are you doing
she had already been in her third year
at the can come on oh why does this
Academy I know I was wondering that too
much so after they find out she's a dog
they go oh we can't have dogs in this
Academy first of all what Ludmila saying
is that there was this all started like
how she was branded as feral and
everything it all started when she there
was this one day or she didn't feel good
and that was the day that she had to be
shooting in during her her classes like
she coughed up like a hairball or
something she like [ __ ] put her let
me at her she started looking around
[ __ ] and [ __ ]
no I just normal guys just normal she's
no well I'm just basing it off of the
report if there's Collymore feral I
don't want to call them alive because
I'd be [ __ ] up you're related to Colin
Farrell yeah but anyway she ended up
going to the medical office to try to
get a sick leave to get out of that
class because she said that she was
feeling really dizzy and she was scared
that she might shoot someone and so with
that comment that's the the Academy is
claiming that that is the reason why
they kicked her out for inappropriate
behavior because of the fact that she
said she might shoot someone in class I
think she means she might do something
on accident while she's shooting it
she's kind of
I don't want to go yeah yeah then the
the Academy I got it
I'm understand her joke I don't speak
Russian I still understood yeah and so
like the the official report says that
she was kicked out because of
inappropriate behavior because of that
because she was responsible enough to
turn so nobody likes her a literal [ __ ]
see I knew she was a [ __ ]
[Music]
flowers and like damn this is like
Hansel Gretel like oh you know like what
is that what is that a pyramid take so
many sweet what look like the biggest
cupcakes have ever seen ginger bread
winter Gretel anything you've got one
long a scandal I want to I'm so curious
what does that taste like
again [ __ ] biggest prequels on the
planet in Russian cupcake so where did
you buy that [ __ ] in Russia again Marty
seriously gonna eat all that [ __ ] though
cuz bank attention to the picture baby
wait the more you stare at it that
little baby's like I'm gonna eat it I
know this baby ready to go will a
cupcake first or long candle blow hahaha
select will be cupcake a little cupcake
yo why does it look like they're trapped
in 1963
no Alex crazy yeah but like once this
story came out like all the media just
round with it saying like you know she
was kicked out of the police academy
because of her feral past and like that
just abusing feral pass it has no
[ __ ] feral pass well I mean I'm it's
just record it's just crazy that from
three to what age she was a doggie I
know that her mom or like she got taken
away from her mom when she was three she
got adopted by her mom when she was five
so there's only get two years Oh what
could have been like one from one to two
it could have been from like yeah from a
baby to three and then that was she was
three is when she got taken away from
her mom and taken to this orphanage so
she might just like have some relapse
from time to time like I meant excuse me
you better not be missing no just
kidding news uploads so go down and
subscribe for our channel so you can see
more video okay
and there's another one up here check it
out
[Music]